we have a voicemail number its 2192
david p here is a caller who is telling
me to do what i want to do what do I
mean let's take a listen yeah yeah I'm
viewer and just looking at your what is
it here audience disagrees Bigley you
know I wouldn't worry too much about
audience response I mean go ahead and
feel free to do what you do and host it
but who really cares what people say I
just do what you guys do your shows
pretty good it's like a political
science class it's it's a good show man
all right take it easy I like that
instead of caring what the audience
thinks he's referring to this segment
where we we said do you want double live
calls on Fridays or classic interviews
by the way voting on that is over okay
so we're not taking any more votes on
that and and I reacted by saying people
feel really strongly about this we're
trying to figure out a way to you know
make sure we have something for everyone
in this caller saying David who cares
what other people think just do the show
you want to do the thing is if we don't
have an audience I have to care to some
degree not about political opinions
right I'm going to do the show with my
opinion I don't care about what other
people think about my political opinion
but the format of the show needs to be
something people like because otherwise
we won't have an audience then i can do
whatever i bought but nobody will watch
or listen interesting and he also says
the show is pretty good exactly are you
endorsing make changes make it better
and sometimes you want to reach out to
the audience to help you come up with
ideas right this guy thinks the show is
only pretty good why wouldn't I aspire
to make the show really good in his eyes
maybe by making some changes and he
would ask him for his advice maybe
absolutely please call in again but I
like that saying David do what you want
to do yeah and for the most part that's
what we do even when what we want to do
is to ask the audience that's right I'll
doing what we want to do brilliant what
I wanted to do was get audience feedback
about it on the bonus show today India
has something called phone Romeo's who
look for ms right using wrong numbers
i'll explain that i'm going to talk
about the millennial wealth deficit and
this is going to be huge we have
received vegan cheese in the mail from
ashley lynn waldron a viewer and
listener to the show we are going to try
vegan cheese I've never had
vegan quote cheese because that cheese
right cheated on a hazelnut yeah so I
don't know it's it's a sort of hazelnut
spread I don't know how you convert
hazelnuts into a cheese like substance
but anyway we're gonna try it on the
bonus show alright and we will see how
it compares to what we are now calling
the durian incident on the show david
pakman.com slash membership sign up you
are not going to want to miss as trying
vegan cheese today i voted 17 as the
coupon code